I got enemies got a lot of enemies got a  lot of people trying to train me in my  inner cheated police confirm to ET  rapper Drake's tour bus was robbed of  millions of dollars in property on  Tuesday night during a tour stop in  Phoenix Arizona authorities explained  the 29 year olds bus was parked in a  lower garage at the talking stick arena  while he was performing between 10 and  10 15 p.m. a suspect boarded the bus and  removed a briefcase containing an  estimated three million dollars in  jewelry and other property following the  incident a video obtained by TMZ show  Drake visibly frustrated clapping his  hands and waving them around every time  I see him something wrong with it memory  cops tell us the investigation is  ongoing et has reached out to Drake's  rep and the venue for comment